David Boder: Paris, August the 23rd, 1946. The interviewee is Mr. Karl Josephy, 37 years old, born in Austria and lived in Paris since 1938.
David Boder: Also, sagen Sie mir noch mal, Herr Josephy, was ist ihr erster Name, und ...wo sind Sie geboren und ... äh so weiter ...
Karl Josephy: Ja, mein Name ist Karl Josephy, ich bin in Wien geboren am 6. Juni 1909.
David Boder: Und äh, was war die Beschäftigung Ihres Vaters?
Karl Josephy: Mein Vater war zunächst Buchhalter ....
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... später Vorstand in einer Großbank ...
Karl Josephy: .... und später wurde er pensioniert aus Gründen seines Alters.
David Boder: Ja ... äh - wieviel Kinder waren Sie in der Familie?
Karl Josephy: Ein einziges Kind.
David Boder: Sie waren der einzige Sohn in einer Familie?
Karl Josephy: Ja.
David Boder: Was für eine Ausbildung haben Sie gehabt?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe Ausbildung – äh die Mittelschule ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: – die Universität.
David Boder: Was haben Sie in der Universität studiert?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe die Rechte studiert.
David Boder: Haben Sie beendet?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe beendet – bis auf eine einzige Prüfung.
David Boder: Aha ... Nun äh ... und was war Ihre Beschäftigung in Österreich?
Karl Josephy: Ich äh war zunächst in Österreich mit meinen Studien beschäftigt – [part not audible]
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... ferner war ich in einer Industrie - in der Papierbranche tätig - in der Papierindustrie.
David Boder: Warum sind Sie nach - äh - Frankreich übergesiedelt?
Karl Josephy: Ich bin nach Frankreich übergesiedelt weil ich durch die Revolution - durch die nazistische Revolution in Österreich - sowohl in meinem Beruf, in meinem sonstigen intellektuellen Fortkommen und auch politisch gefährdet war
David Boder: Aha.
Karl Josephy: Als Jude.
David Boder: Als Jude?
Karl Josephy: Ja. [Tape break — part not audible]
David Boder: Nun, Herr Josephy, wenn jemand Sie fragen würde, oder wenn Sie ein Buch schreiben würden, was würden Sie als die Hauptpunkte Ihrer Erlebnisse von ’38 bis zur Befreiung - uns erzählen wollen?
Karl Josephy: Als Hauptpunkte würde ich Ihnen zweifellos meine Gefahren und meine Leiden erzählen, die ich vom Moment meiner Arrestation ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... die zugleich meine Frau betraf, mitgemacht habe.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie das anfangen? Wollen sie dann anfangen, wie die Sache in Paris war und wie das ganze äh Unglück - wie Sie von Ihrem ruhigen Leben also äh allmählich rausgerissen wurden.
Karl Josephy: Ich bin ...
David Boder: Erzählen Sie die ganze Geschichte ...
Karl Josephy: Ich bin zu Kriegsbeginn als Engagee Volontär [?] als Freiwilliger für Frankreich eingerückt und habe meinen Militärdienst in Afrika durchgeführt.
David Boder: Was war Ihr Rang?
Karl Josephy: Ich war gemeiner Soldat?
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Ich habe in der Legion Etrangere mein Bestes getan, war auch Freiwilliger für die Front ...
Karl Josephy: Nur haben es die Ereignisse mit sich gebracht durch den überstürzten Waffenstillstand, der von Frankreich gezwungenermaßen geschlossen werden musste ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... dass ich nicht an die Front einrücken konnte und demobilisiert wurde.
David Boder: Wo waren Sie während der Demobilisation?
Karl Josephy: Die Geschichte meiner Demobilisation ist insofern äußerst tragisch ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... da ich nicht demobilisiert wurde so wie jeder französische Soldat oder jeder Ausländer, der schon früher in Frankreich lebte, sondern man verlangte von mir ein tadelloses Aufenthaltspapier und10.000 Francs als Kaution, dass ich nach Frankreich, also, in die Metropole zurückkehren könnte. Da ich weder das Papier, von dem ich nur ein Kopie besaß ...
David Boder: ... das war in Afrika?
Karl Josephy: ... das war in Afrika ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... da ich weder das Papier besaß -bei mir hatte- noch die erforderlichen 10.000 Francs, hielt man mich in Guarta [?] am Rande der Wüste quasi gefangen, ich musste äußerst schwere körperliche Arbeiten vollführen, die Bezahlung war null und die Behandlung sehr schlecht.
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Karl Josephy: Das ist offenbar über Auftrag der Regierung von Marokko geschehen, die natürlich ihre Orders von der französischen Metropole erhielt ...
David Boder: Von Vichy?
Karl Josephy: Von Vichy.
David Boder: Ja. Und was für Arbeiten haben Sie dort gemacht?
Karl Josephy: Wir haben Steine zertrümmert, wir haben große Blöcke Steine zertrümmert, die dazu dienten, einen Ballast für die, zur Errichtung der Bahnlinie, die zum Kongo herunterführen sollte, äh ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... zur - äh - und eben zur Errichtung der Bahnlinie dienen sollte die Noballa [?, word not clear] und Arbeiten vollführten bei 40 bis 60 Grad Hitze
David Boder: Ja bitte nennen Sie Wirkungen [?, word not clear] ...
Karl Josephy: ... vom Schatten war natürlich keine Rede ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... und mussten diese Arbeiten durchgeführt werden in einem Rekordtempo und unter - und unter Aufsicht der französischen Sergeanten [?, word not clear] ...
David Boder: Ja. Nun, und was hat man dafür bezahlt?
Karl Josephy: Man hat dafür 1 Francs täglich bezahlt.
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ...und ist dieses Geld immer erst sehr spät angelangt.
David Boder: Und was hat man zu essen bekommen?
Karl Josephy: Die Kost war nicht hinreichend für diese schwere Arbeit.
David Boder: .... ja, äh, aber die haben das Essen besorgt, nicht wahr?
Karl Josephy: Das Essen wurde da durch das Arbeitslager, 5 km weit entfernt von dem, von dem ......
David Boder: ... Bauplatz weg ...
Karl Josephy: ... Bauplatz befand, wurde mit Camions herbeigeschafft und, äh, ebenso wie die Wasserversorgung.
David Boder: Aha, was hat man Ihnen zum Beispiel Essen gegeben, am Morgen?
Karl Josephy: Am Morgen gab es schwarzen Kaffee und ein Stück Brot, das war auch schon alles.
David Boder: Und, äh, Zucker?
Karl Josephy: Der Kaffee war — [?, not clearly audible] ... darin in vielleicht ein Spur Süßigkeit.
David Boder: Das hat ihnen gezuckert [?, not clearly audible].
Karl Josephy: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, und um 12 Uhr, um 1 Uhr, Mittagszeit?
Karl Josephy: ... ja, zu dieser Zeit bekam man eine Suppe, ein Stück Fleisch, Gemüse und gelegentlich ein paar Wein ...
David Boder: ... etwas Wein ...
Karl Josephy: ... etwas Wein.
David Boder: Also, äh, wie hat man das bedient ... haben Sie in einem Speisesaal gegessen oder in einem ... wo haben Sie gegessen?
Karl Josephy: ... in keiner Weise, denn ein Speisesaal war ja tatsächlich nicht vorhanden.
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... wir haben in Erdlöchern, die wir selbst gegraben haben, gewohnt, da es wegen der schrecklichen Hitze nicht möglich war, in Zelten zu wohnen
David Boder: Oh ...
Karl Josephy: ... in diese Erdlöcher, nicht wahr, haben wir uns zurückgezogen während der Mittagspause, hinsichtlich erschöpft, und haben die Mahlzeiten in unseren alten Militärgamellen heruntergeschlungen, wie es eben war.
David Boder: Was sind Militärgamellen, Geschirr?
Karl Josephy: Das ist das alte Militärgeschirr. dass wir behalten hatten noch von der Kriegszeit her.
David Boder: Wer war mit Ihnen, was für Leute waren mit Ihnen?
Karl Josephy: Das waren mit mir sämtlich jüdische Engagee Volontär (?) für Frankreich, die ebenso wie ich weder das erforderliche Geld noch die erforderlichen Papiere vorlegen konnten, um sofort demobilisiert zu werden.
David Boder: Aha - waren bloß Juden in dieser ganzen Baugeschichte?
Karl Josephy: Es waren fünf Gruppen von Juden ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... und außerdem mehrere Gruppen von republikanischen Spaniern, die durch den Umsturz in Spanien nach Frankreich geflüchtet waren, und dorten- und von dort aus nach Afrika übersiedelt wurden und ebenfalls Zwangsarbeiten vollführten, äh, mit einer Bezahlung gleich Null und unter den selben Umständen wie wir selber.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, wie lange hat das gedauert?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe mich genau aufgehalten in Guarta (?), das heißt der Ausgangsstation für die Bahn, die zum Niger führen sollte, zum Kongo und zum Niger führen sollte, vom 21. Dezember 1940 bis zum 19. Juli 1941.
David Boder: Ja. Wo war Ihre Frau?
Karl Josephy: Ich war zu diesem Moment noch nicht verheiratet.
David Boder: Sie waren noch nicht verheiratet. Was ist dann passiert, wie Sie mit der Arbeit fertig waren?
Karl Josephy: Ich wurde am 19. Juli demobilisiert, nachdem man mir endlich nach langem Warten die Papiere geschickt hatte und ich mir die erforderlichen 10000 Francs ausgeborgt habe ...
David Boder: Von wo, von wem?
Karl Josephy: Die hat mir ein Kollege geborgt um mir die Rückkehr nach Frankreich zu ermöglichen.
David Boder: Wieviel war der Francs damals wert? Zum Dollar?
Karl Josephy: Kann ich Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen ...
David Boder: ... so ungefähr ...
Karl Josephy: In dieser Zeit ...
Karl Josephy: Wir müssen bedenken, nicht wahr, dass wohl das Verhältnis 1:60 gewesen ist ...
David Boder: 1:60 ...
Karl Josephy: 1:60 – jaja ...
David Boder: Ja ... – ungefähr ...
Karl Josephy: Jaja ...
David Boder: Und wer hat das weiter Geld gehabt?
Karl Josephy: Es waren immerhin einige Kollegen, die sich das Geld schicken ließen von Frankreich ...
David Boder: Oh ...
Karl Josephy: ... um ebenfalls demobilisiert zu werden ...
Karl Josephy: ... denn Bargeld hat fast niemand von uns besessen, es hat sich ja bei den Leuten die in Afrika gearbeitet haben, zu 90 Prozent um arme Flüchtlinge aus Deutschland, Österreich, Polen und Belgien gehandelt hat.
David Boder: Aha. Also dann hat Ihnen ein Freund das Geld geliehen und Sie haben die Kaution aufge [fraction, word not finished] ... haben Sie jemals die Kaution zurückbekommen?
Karl Josephy: Diese Kaution war mehr ein Vorzeigegeld, das heißt im Moment wo ich die Kaution vorgelegt habe, hatte ich ja das Geld ja wieder in die Hand bekommen ...
David Boder: Oh ...
Karl Josephy: ... und sofort restituiert.
David Boder: Und Sie haben das bezahlt, naja ... Sie haben einfach das Geld nun gekriegt, um es zu zeigen ....
Karl Josephy: ... um es zu zeigen in der Buchhaltung.
David Boder: Ah so. Und wohin sind Sie dann gegangen?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe, nachdem ich in Frankreich keinen Menschen gehabt habe, aufs Geratewohl das Departement Gard als Wohnstätte angegeben ...
David Boder: ... und wo ist Gard?
Karl Josephy: Gard ist ein kleines Departement im Süden Frankreichs mit der Hauptstadt Nimes.
David Boder: ... wie weit von Spanien?
Karl Josephy: ... äh, mvon Spanien 400 Kilometer.
David Boder: Ja, wie weit von Lyon oder Marseilles?
Karl Josephy: .... von Marseilles 50 Kilometer.
David Boder: Aha, na ...
David Boder: Das ist dann nicht weit von dem Mediter- Mittelmeer...
Karl Josephy: Ja, ja, durchaus im Süden, ...
David Boder: Aha.
Karl Josephy: ... nicht wahr, mit südlichem Klima, in der südlichen Zone von Frankreich ...
David Boder: Also weiter, dann, und ... was haben sie sich etabliert und was haben sie dann getan?
Karl Josephy: Im Department Gard verrichtete ich schwere Arbeiten, ich habe Kohlen getragen, ich habe Holz gehackt, ...
David Boder: ... aber das war freie Arbeit ...
Karl Josephy: ... weil ich ja mittelos war ... dass war allerdings freie Arbeit ...
David Boder: ... und sie haben dafür bezahlt bekommen ...
Karl Josephy: Ich habe dafür bezahlt bekommen, ich habe schwer gearbeitet - aber ich habe mein Leben verdient ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... und ich war überall gut angesehen. Man wusste dass ich ein früherer Intellektueller bin, und hat mich demgemäß auch anständig behandelt, wenn ich auch schwer arbeiten musste ... [pause]
David Boder: Also weiter, nun was hat Ihnen denn passiert? Wie hat das aufgehört?
Karl Josephy: Die Situation verschlimmerte sich vom Moment des Regierungsamtes des von Lavale, der durch die Verträge mit Deutschland eine entsprechende Pression ausübte.... sowohl auf alle Elemente, die nicht, die nicht, die nicht beliebt waren - insbesondere auch die Juden ...
David Boder: Ja ... nun?
Karl Josephy: Dadurch ... hatte es sich ereignet, dass ich zwei Monate nach meiner Hochzeit ...
David Boder: Wen haben Sie, wann haben Sie geheiratet?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe im Juni ’42 geheiratet.
David Boder: Wen haben sie denn geheiratet?
Karl Josephy: Meine Frau ist äh Polin, die aber vorher in Österreich lebte und ...
David Boder: Eine Jüdin?
Karl Josephy: Eine Jüdin ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... die sich mutterseelenallein in Frankreich befand ...
Karl Josephy: ...und, äh, ganz allein auf sich angewiesen war, und sich durch Schneiderarbeiten immerhin ganz gut fortbrachte ...
David Boder: ... hmhm ...
Karl Josephy: Nachdem unser Schicksal ungefähr ein gemeinsames war, dauerte es nicht lange, dass wir uns heirateten.
David Boder: Ja? Nun ... und was bewirkt das jetzt?
Karl Josephy: Wir sind im, da wir infolge eines gewissen Wohnungsmangels nicht zusammen wohnte, wohnten ... ähm, ereignete es sich, dass ich am 24. August 1942 um halbdrei Uhr früh von meiner Frau in Begleitung von zwei Inspektoren der Gendarmerie geweckt wurde, die uns zehn Minuten Zeit gaben, unsere, unser Gepäck zu packen und sofort in einem Camion, der bereits bereitstand, nach Nimes herunter zu fahren ...
David Boder: Und warum ...
Karl Josephy: Also herunter zu fahren ...
David Boder: ... war der das der allgemeine Arrest damals oder man hat Sie bloß ausgesucht?
Karl Josephy: ... man hat sämtliche Juden, das heißt es waren insgesamt nur 8 aus dem kleinen Städtchen. in dem ich wohnte, in der Nacht ohne vorheriges, eh, ohne vorherigeWarnung ...
David Boder: Warnung...
Karl Josephy: ... Warnung, aus den Betten geholt, um uns, womöglich ohne dass es viel aufällt, sofort abzutransportieren, und leider wussten wir ja schon ungefähr, was das bedeuten konnte.
David Boder: How, äh, warum hat man gewusst dass sie Juden waren?
Karl Josephy: Das hat man gewusst, weil ja die Juden seinerzeit in Frankreich, das heißt, seit dem Vichy-Regime, gezwungen waren, eine Deklaration als Juden abzugeben.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, und wohin wurden Sie dann geschickt?
Karl Josephy: Ich wurde von dort ...
David Boder: ... mit Ihrer Frau ...
Karl Josephy: ... mit meiner Frau zusammen in einer, in einem Camion nach Nimes, also 15 Kilometer nach Süden, verschickt ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... um dorten eine weitere Verschickung abzuwarten. In Nimes fanden wir bereits mehrere tausend Juden, die aus dem ganzen Department und dem Nachbardepartment zusammen getrommelt worden waren, vor, die alle auf ihren Abtransport in ein Zentralsammellager warteten.
David Boder: ... nun ...
Karl Josephy: Dieser Transport ...
David Boder: ... das war noch bevor die Deutschen Nimes, äh, eingenommen haben?
Karl Josephy: Jaja, das war noch das war noch im August ’42, das heißt, bevor die Deutschen in die sogenannte freie Zone übergetreten sind, nicht wahr, und ganz Frankreich auf diese Weise endgültig okkupierten ...
David Boder: Amerika war noch nicht, es war in ’42
Karl Josephy: Das war 42, ja ...
David Boder: ... also Amerika war schon im Krieg?
Karl Josephy: Amerika war schon im Krieg, ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Karl Josephy: Wir wurden von Nimes mit einem, unter schwerer Bewachung mit einigen Nahrungsmitteln nur ausgestattet, die uns von der jüdischen Gemeinde in Nimes auf den Weg mitgegeben wurden ...
David Boder: Wie, ist die Gemeinde geblieben, hat man die Gemeinde nicht arretiert?
Karl Josephy: Es wurden einige Gemeindemitglieder, das heißt die Vorstandsmitglieder beibehalten, doch waren diese von der Gestapo abhängig ....
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... und inner ... und konnten natürlich nicht so agieren wie sie wollten ...
Karl Josephy: es handelt sich ... sich hier um Franzosen ...
David Boder: ... französische Juden ...
Karl Josephy: um französische Juden, weil man zu dieser Zeit zunächst nur die Juden, die ausländischen Juden ...
David Boder: ... genommen hat ...
Karl Josephy: ... genommen hat ...
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Karl Josephy: Wir wurden also von dort, von [cough] ... von der Bahnstation von Nimes nach Les Milles befördert, das ist ein kleiner Ort in der Nähe von Aix ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... also auch nur cirka 40 Kilometer von Marseille entfernt ...
Karl Josephy: Dort befand sich eine große Ziegelfabrik, die bis zu 5 bis 6000 Menschen beherbergen konnte - dorten warteten ganz gewöhnliche Strohlager alles, alles eh, recht primitiv aufgebaut, und dieses Lager war nur dazu bestimmt, um die dorten internierten Juden binnen kürzestem ohne große, ohne großes Federlesens weiter in das berühmte Camp von Drancy ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... zu befördern ...
Karl Josephy: ... und von dorten nach Deutschand endgültig zu deportieren ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: Wir haben dorten ...
David Boder: Waren Sie noch immer mit Ihrer Frau zusammen oder waren Männer und Frauen schon apartiert?
Karl Josephy: wir waren immer - ich war immer mit meiner Frau zusammen, lediglich die Schlafstätten waren für Männer und Frauen getrennt ...
David Boder: ... aha ja nun ...
Karl Josephy: ... dass, eh, haben sich dann ...
David Boder: ... haben Sie arbeiten müssen? ...
Karl Josephy: Ich habe dort nicht arbeiten müssen ... ich habe aber, ähä, infolge meiner persönlichen Mittel-, Mittellosigkeit verschiedene kleinere Arbeiten vollführt, speziell für ältere Herren habe ich jetzt es natürlich gratis gemacht, aber wenn man mich zu einer Arbeit geholt hat, die schwieriger war oder im gemeinsamen Interesse, so hab ich auch von der Lagerleitung einen kleinen Beitrag bezahlt bekommen.
David Boder: Die Lagerleitung war jüdisch?
Karl Josephy: Die Lagerleitung war nicht jüdisch. Die Lagerleitung war vollständig von Vichy abhängig ... Es waren darunter auch, eh, das heisst zur Mehrzahl sogar Menschen, die uns äusserst schwer behandelten, nicht wahr , und die keinerlei Ausnahmen für uns machen wollten und sich sehr wenig um den Gesundheitszustand der Menschen kümmerten ...
David Boder: Aber denn, dennoch haben sie etwas bezahlt irgend etwas ...
Karl Josephy: ... ja, bis zu einem gewissen Ausmaß ...
David Boder: ... ja, nun - und wie lange waren sie dort und was hat dort passiert?
Karl Josephy: Ich - es haben sich dorten furchtbare Schreckensszenen abgespielt - speziell im Moment, wo man die Leute herausholte, wo man die Namen - aus den, aus ihren Lagern herausholte - wo man die Namen aufrief, die deportiert werden sollten ...Es gab Selbstmorde, es gab Leute die sich versteckten ... Und so hätte es naturlich auch so weit kommen konnen, dass man meine Frau und mich deportiert ...Wir konnten hier aber von einem sehr glücklichen Umstand Gebrauch machen:Wir haben nämlich, wir haben nämlich profitiert von einer Verordnung von Vichy, die sämtliche Leute, die Kinder unter zwei Jahren hatten, nicht deportierten ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: Wir konnten davon profitieren, weil wir Gottseidank die Dokumente über unser Kind bei uns hatten ...
David Boder: Sie hatten ein Kind schon dann ...?
Karl Josephy: Wir hatten ein Kind und wir haben uns verheiratet infolge der unsicheren Umstände, nicht wahr ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
David Boder: Und wie alt war das Kind?
Karl Josephy: ... erfolgte die eigentliche Heirat später ...
Karl Josephy: ... das Kind war ein Jahr und zehn Monate alt.
David Boder: War das Kind bevor Ihrer Heirat geboren? Nein?
Karl Josephy: Das Kind war vor meiner Heirat geboren.
David Boder: Ja, und dann haben Sie sich verheiratet ...
Karl Josephy: Ja, und dann haben wir das Kind legalisiert ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Und es war zu dieser Zeit, wo wir selber nur Refugee waren, wo ich in Afrika war ...
Karl Josephy: und meine Frau ganz woanders, nicht wahr ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... war gar keine Möglichkeit vorhanden, sich um die Formalitäten so zu kümmern wie
Karl Josephy: ... das sein sollte...
David Boder: Ja, nun ...
Karl Josephy: Dieses Kind hat uns also ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... ohne Übertreibung das Leben gerettet ...
Karl Josephy: Denn, äh, ... wir wurden, äh, wir wurden nicht befreit wie ich es wollte, weil ich immer wieder darauf hinwies, dass ich gewesener Freiwilliger für Frankreich war, doch hatte man davon durchaus gar kein, he, daraus machte man mir gar keinen Vorteil, sondern ich weiss es, dass man auch engagee voluntaires glattweg nach Deutschland deportiert hat ...
David Boder: Nun?
Karl Josephy: Wir wurden von dort in ein anderes Lager geschafft, wobei man uns bedeutete, dass das schon ein große ... eine - ein großes Glück war, dorten hin zu kommen. Das war auch in sofern der Fall, weil von sämtlichen Insassen von diesem furchtbaren Lager ...
David Boder: Was war der Name von dem Lager?
Karl Josephy: Les Milles ...
David Boder: Das furchtbare Lager ...
Karl Josephy: Das ist ein ... ich nenne das furchtbares Lager ohne Übertreibung ...
David Boder: Nun ja ... ... und dann wohin wurden Sie dann geschickt?
Karl Josephy: Ich wurde von dort in ein anderes Lager geschickt, in das Lager ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: Brechen wir ab, oder ... ? ... [interruption]
David Boder: ... nun ...
Karl Josephy: Wir wurden also von dort in ein anderes Lager geschafft, immer unter schwerer Bewachung und be ... und ... befanden sich mit uns circa 40 andere Personen, die der sicheren Deportation aus diesem oder jenem Grunde aus einer gewissen Priorität entrinnen konnten, um in einem anderen Lager interniert zu werden.
Karl Josephy: Dieses andere Lager war das Lager von Noyes in dem Department Haute Garonne ... Über das Lager selbst lässt sich sagen, dass die Behandlung äusserst streng war ...
David Boder: Franzosen?
Karl Josephy: Franzosen. Ja.
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Die Behandlung war äusserst streng, die, äh, die Ernährung katastrophal ...was die Ernährung betrifft, waren wir hauptsächlich auf zusätzliche Spenden des Secours National und dem Anfang auch der amerikanischen Quäker angewiesen ...
David Boder: Was ist das Secours National ...
Karl Josephy: Das Secours National, ja, ist die französische Wohltätigkeits-, eh Behörde, wenn sie wollen, die uns gelegentlich Pakete schickte oder auch gewisse Nahrungsmittel, gewisse billige Nahrungsmittel, nicht wahr, die dann den guten Zweck hatten, uns doch ein bisschen unsere viel zu schmale Kost aufzubessern.
David Boder: ... und die Quäker waren auch dort während des Krieges?
Karl Josephy: Das ist eine sehr interessante Sache - die Quäker hatten sich nämlich bei uns installieren wollen, und hatten uns zunächst mit einem, eine Hilfe in Form von Nahrungsmitteln geschickt. Als sie sich aber endgültig in unserem Lager auch trotz des Krieges etablieren wollten, um den unglücklichen Internierten zu helfen, hat der Direktor dies glattweg verweigert.
David Boder: ... hmhm - nun?
Karl Josephy: ...äh, was die Hygiene in diesem Lager ...
David Boder: ... Augenblick?
Karl Josephy: ... ja bitte [unintelligible (sprechen Sie hier?)]
Karl Josephy: ja, was die Hygiene betrifft, so kann man sagen, waren wir nicht zu schlecht untergebracht in Holzbarracken, es gab auch Duschbäder, für die Reinlichkeit war gesorgt, ja, letzlich, ich betone es immer wieder, waren nur die Nahrungsverhältnisse, die katastrophal waren - es sind tatsächlich Personen gestorben, von denen man behauptet hat, dass sie Darmkrankheiten gehabt haben - aber sie sind Hungers gestorben.
David Boder: ...ja - nun sagen sie mal, und sie waren noch immer mit Ihrer Frau zusammen?
Karl Josephy: Ich war noch immer mit meiner Frau zusammen, und habe verzweifelte Versuche gemacht, mich auf legale Weise aus diesem Lager zu befreien, indem ich Eingaben machte, indem ich auf mein Schicksal und auf mein Kind hinwies ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: Und so hoffte befreit, zu werden.
David Boder: Now, wie haben sie das Kind ernährt?
Karl Josephy: Das Kind konnte ich ja gar nicht ernähren, denn es war ja nicht bei uns. Das Kind war ja schon früher von meiner Frau zur OSE geschafft worden.
David Boder: ... ohh ...
Karl Josephy: diese große Organisation, die ja zweifellos bekannt ist ...
David Boder: ...ohh ...ja also, wann Sie haben sich von Ihrem Kinde getrennt? War das schon lange ...
Karl Josephy: Ich hatte mich von meinem ... ich habe mich von meinem Kinde getrennt schon nach meiner schon nach der Geburt des Kindes, denn ich war ja noch in Afrika. Ich war in Afrika ich hatte nur Urlaub ...
David Boder: Nein, ich mein, wenn wurde das Kind von der Mutter getrennt?
Karl Josephy: Das war ... [pause] ... im Oktober 41
David Boder: Aha...
Karl Josephy: Im Oktober 1941 ...
David Boder: Aber im ersten Lager, wo sie waren, war das Kind mit ihnen?
Karl Josephy: Das Kind war nie in dem Lager mit uns.
David Boder: Ohh, aber trotzdem, da sie eh ein Kind hatten, so konnten sie nicht deportiert werden ...
Karl Josephy: Nein, konnte ich vorläufig nicht deportiert werden.
David Boder: No, wie hat die OSE während des Krieges funktioniert?
Karl Josephy: Die OSE hat OSE hat ausgezeichnet funktioniert, das heißt, die war schon vorher meistens von den Juden die irgend etwas Böses geahnt haben, verständigt worden, dass sie sich der kleinen Kinder annehmen sollen, weil man ja die Kinder nicht in die Lager mitnehmen wollte, sofern sich das verhindern ließ.
David Boder: Ja und so, wo war das Kind untergebracht?
Karl Josephy: Das Kind war in Oeyl [?] in einem kleinen Ort in den Pyrenäen untergebracht
David Boder: ... bei ...
Karl Josephy: ... war ...
David Boder: ... bei wem?
Karl Josephy: ... war untergebracht mit einem Heim vom roten Kreuz.
David Boder: Oh ...
Karl Josephy: Croix Rouge Francaise.
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: Nicht wahr ... wohin das Kind durch die durch die Vermittlung der OSE gegeben wurde.
David Boder: Aha ...nun, weiter, bitte.
Karl Josephy: Wir haben also verschiedene legale Versuche gemacht, uns zu befreien, die leider nicht geglückt sind, weil der Präfekt von meinem früheren Department, mir den Aufenthalt, das heißt die Rückkehr glattwegs verweigert hat.
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: Ich habe später eine Eingabe gemacht, um in ein sogenanntes Groupement des Travailleurs Etrangers affektiert zu werden.
Karl Josephy: Das waren Gruppen von ausländischen Juden oder auch Spaniern, das heißt also von Ausländern ...
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... von mittellosen Ausländern, die dadurch, dass sie einer Gruppe angehörten, vom Staat überwacht wurden, und äh, die Arbeiten zu gemein - zu gemeinnützigen Zwecken vollführten, gelegentlich auch ein Barraquement zur Verfügung hatten und im Großen und Ganzen nicht schlecht gehalten waren.
David Boder: Konnten Sie dann ihre Frau mitnehmen?
Karl Josephy: Ich konnte meine Frau nicht mitnehmen, denn für Frauen war dies nicht vorgesehen. Ich habe also, ...
David Boder: Aha ...
Karl Josephy: ... ich habe also im Februar den Bescheid bekommen, mich in eines dieser Lager zu begeben, in einem Groupement des Travailleurs Etrangers, und habe natürlich ein Lager ausgesucht, dass sich in der nächsten Nähe meiner Frau befand, weil wir die Absicht hatten, meine Frau zu befreien, im Moment wo ich selber soweit die Freiheit hatte, mein Leben draußen zu verdienen. Diese Möglichkeit war uns tatsächlich gegeben, nur war diese Möglichkeit meistens nur theoretisch ...
David Boder: Ja –nun?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe, ich bin also von dem Lager in Noyes in ein anderes Lager überführt worden, in das Groupement von Septfonds, Septfonds in Carnet Garonne. Das befand sich cirka 100 Kilometer von Noyes entfernt, also leider viel zu weit von meiner Frau, wo ich ursprünglich, wo ich sie doch ursprünglich besuchen wollte und meine Schritte unternehmen wollte, um sie zu befreien. In Septfonds selbst waren skandalöse Verhältnisse, man hat uns gar keine Freiheiten gelassen, wir mussten auch dort Steine klopfen ... von genau ... war unmöglich, wir hatten eh ... und wir waren allen möglichen Drangsalierungen eines ausgesprochen antisemitischen Chefs ausgesetzt.
David Boder: Franzose?
Karl Josephy: Franzose.
David Boder: Nun?
Karl Josephy: Ich kann ihnen auch den Namen sagen. Nicht wahr. Dieser Mann wurde bestraft, nicht wahr, genauso wie der Lagerleiter von Noyes, nicht wahr, schwer bestraft wegen Kolla-, Kollaboration ...
David Boder: Was nennen sie schwer bestraft?
Karl Josephy: Na ja, er hat ja, er ist zunächst selber interniert worden und wird wohl auch eine Körperstrafe bekommen haben.
David Boder: Ah –nun. Resume.
Karl Josephy: In der - in der - während des Aufenthaltes im Septfonds begannen nun die berühmten Deportationen von Noyes am ...
David Boder: Nun, das, wo ihre Frau war ...
Karl Josephy: Nein, nicht wo meine Frau war, auch von dort wurde deportiert -
David Boder: ... ja ...
Karl Josephy: Die Deportationen setzten vom Moment, wo ich arretiert wurde, unausgesetzt fort ...
David Boder: Aha.
Karl Josephy: Wir hatten nur einen schwachen Schutz durch unser Kind.
David Boder: Ja –nun?
Karl Josephy: Eine besonders schreckliche Zeit verlebte ich in Septfonds Ende Februar und Anfang März des Jahres 1943. Die Sache war zum Schluss so, dass von den circa 200 Lagerinsassen im Septfonds ganze 20 Mann übrig blieben. Man hat keine Familienväter geschont, man hat selber nicht Franzosen geschont, nicht Leute mit französischen Verwandten, hat gar keine Rücksichten mehr genommen ...
David Boder: Wie, sind das Franzosen dort gewesen?
Karl Josephy: Es haben sich tatsächlich Leute vorgefunden, die französische Verwandte gehabt haben oder vorgegeben haben, Franzosen zu sein. Sie müssen nicht vergessen, dass es auch ein Speziallager in Septfonds gegeben hat, wo man verdächtige politische Elemente festgehalten hat.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Karl Josephy: Es hat sich also im Laufe von Februar und März das Lager von Septfonds infolge der ständigen Deportationen derart geleert, dass wir zum Schluss nur mehr 20 Leute übrig waren, und es ist wie ein Wunder, dass ich selbst darunter gewesen bin.
David Boder: Nun
Karl Josephy: Ich habe unter dieser Zeit eine demande gemacht, die meine Frau befreien zu lassen. Diese ‘demande’ wurde später im Papierkorb des Herrn Demoulin, Demoulin, des Herrn Lagerchefs vorgefunden, der mir ernsthaft ins Gesicht gesagt hat, dass er sein Möglichstes tun würde, und es sofort im Papierkorb, und die Überreste meiner demande sofort im Papierkorb geworfen ...
David Boder: ... geworfen ...
Karl Josephy: ... geworfen hat.
David Boder: ... nun?
Karl Josephy: ... ähm, die Situation im, im Lager Septfonds wurde nach wie vor, wurde immer ärger, immer unhaltbarer , zum Schluss hatten wir in vollständiges Ausgangsverbot, weil sehr viele Evasionen vorkamen ...
David Boder: ... hmhm ...
Karl Josephy: Endlich haben wir durch, eh, ist eine Inspektion gekommen, die angefordert hat, Arbeiter im Holz als Waldarbeiter im Department Cantal und uns freigestellt hat, und uns freigestellt hat, uns dazu zu melden. Also die wenigen Leute, die von dem Lager noch übrigblieben, haben natürlich sofort alle verlangt, von dieser Hölle von Septfonds versetzt zu werden.
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Und so bin ich am 14. Juli 1943 nach Cantal übersiedelt, noch immer unter der Form eines groupement des travallieurs etrangers ...
David Boder: Was für eine Holzarbeit haben Sie denn verstanden?
Karl Josephy: Holzarbeit haben wir gar keine verstanden, es war, wir warn alle nur Laien, wir waren alle nur Amateure, wenn Sie wollen, denn, kaum dass jemand von uns verstanden hat, eine Säge oder eine Axt richtig in die Hand zu nehmen. Die Arbeit ...
David Boder: ... kamen ...
Karl Josephy: Ja ...
David Boder: ...ja ...
Karl Josephy: Die Arbeit bestand darin, dass man Bäume fällen musste im Born,
David Boder: ... aha ...
Karl Josephy: Die Bäume mussten gefällt werden und zugerichtet werden. Und das war natürlich schwere Arbeit, die aber verhältnismäßig gut bezahlt war.
David Boder: Oh, sie haben für die Arbeit bezahlt bekommen?
Karl Josephy: Ja, ich bin ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Ja dieses Groupement war sehr anständig. Wir haben bezahlt bekommen nach denselben Tarifen wie französische Arbeiter ...
Karl Josephy: Und wohnten zusammen in einem Baraquement. Wir waren nach der Arbeit vollständig freie Menschen. Wir erhielten auch Kleidung vom Groupement. Und wenn wir nicht so isoliert von der sonstigen Zivilisierung gewesen wären, wären wir dort ganz glücklich gewesen – und ...
David Boder: Wieviel hat man dort gezahlt pro Tag?
Karl Josephy: Man hat 9 Francs pro Stunde gezahlt.
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Und eh man konnte also auf 70 bis 80 Francs ...
David Boder: ... die ...
Karl Josephy: ... gelangen.
David Boder: ...ja - und das Essen musste man sich selber kaufen.
Karl Josephy: Das Essen wurde von uns selbst bezahlt, es wurde uns mit 40 Francs pro Tag angerechnet, vielleicht ein etwas hoher Preis zu dieser Zeit, aber wir haben ausgezeichnet gegessen und ich muss sagen, dass ich seit meiner Rückkehr nach Frankreich von Afrika nie so gut gegessen habe.
David Boder: ... nun?
Karl Josephy: ... eh ...
David Boder: ... und wie weit waren Sie von Ihrer Frau?
Karl Josephy: ...von meiner Frau war ich nunmehr sehr weit entfernt, wenn sie wollen 300 Kilometer ungefähr.
David Boder: ...also von Ihrer Frau waren Sie sehr weit – nun?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe natürlich wieder sofort Schritte unternommen, um meine Frau aus dem schrecklichen Lager zu befreien, unterdessen habe ich ihr natürlich von dort Pakete geschickt, so dass sich ihre, ihre, eh, Lage ge ...
David Boder: ...Lage gebessert hat.
Karl Josephy: ... Lage gebessert hat.
David Boder: ... wie, hat man die Pakete durchgehen lassen?
Karl Josephy: Man hat, eh, man hat prinzipiell im Lager von Noyes sämtliche Pakete kontrolliert, wenn man zuviel Brot gefunden hat oder zuviel Fleisch oder ähnliche besonders wertvolle Nahrungsmittel, wurden sie glattweg konfisziert.
David Boder: ja, ... [not audible]
Karl Josephy: das ist unangenehm ... Pardon.
David Boder: ... also? Nun ja – nun?
Karl Josephy: ... eh ...
David Boder: ... nun ... richten Sie sich hier zu meinem Gerät.
Karl Josephy: ... ja ...
David Boder: ...nun?
Karl Josephy: Ich, eh, habe, wie gesagt, meiner Frau Pakete geschickt und, eh, sofort Schritte unternommen, um sie befreien zu lassen, da es ja nunmehr einen Nachweis erbringen konnte, dass ich mein Leben verdiene und mit meinem Gehalt auch für meine Frau aufkommen könnte...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Diese, dieses Ansuchen habe ich meinem Chef von der, eh, von von dieser Holzabteilung vorgelegt. Er hat sich für sehr gut befunden, hat sie sofort weiter geleitet. Und nun hatte ich tatsächlich einige Hoffnung, dass meine Frau befreit werden würde.
Karl Josephy: Dies war auch tatsächlich der Fall, ich danke noch heute Gott dafür, denn es hat sich herausgestellt, dass 15 Tage nach meiner Befreiung sämtliche Personen, die in der Baracke und der anschließenden Baracke meiner Frau waren, nach Deutschland deportiert wurden, ein Schicksal, das sie natürlich auch getroffen hätte, wenn sie eben nicht befreit worden wäre.
David Boder: Nun – wo sind Sie von dort hingegangen?
Karl Josephy: Ich bin, weil mir die Arbeit im Holz zu schwer gefallen ist, weil ich, eh, furchtbare Muskelschmerzen hatte und ich infolge, eh, meines kleinen Herzfehlers nicht dafür geeignet war, in eine Fabrik versetzt worden, in der man Holzsessel, Holzlehnstühle und Spielsachen für Kinder erzeugte.
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Ich musste wohl auch dort hart, härter arbeiten, aber ich hatte wenigstens ein Dach über dem Kopf, und hatte ...
David Boder: War das dann schon, eh, nachdem Amerika im Krieg war?
Karl Josephy: Jaja, das ist ...
David Boder: Also waren die Deutschen schon in ganz Frankreich?
Karl Josephy: In dieser Zeit waren die Deutschen in ganz Frankreich.
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Und es war natürlich ein schrecklicher Druck auf die Bevölkerung ausgeübt. Und speziell die Juden taten ihr Möglichstes, sich zu verstecken, nicht wahr, und halten sich so gut sie konnten.
David Boder: Ja – nun?
Karl Josephy: Ich eh ich blieb also in dieser Fabrik, die sich nicht weit von meinem ursprünglichen Holzbetrieb befand. Noch bis zum 20. August – bis zum 20. April 1944. Das heißt noch etwas länger als zur die endgültige – nein ... Ich blieb dort bis zum 20. April 1945, also noch etwas länger über die Liberation heraus.
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Während die, während dieser Zeit kam tatsächlich auch von der Präfektur in Cantal ein Schreiben, wonach man mich als früheren engagee voluntaire endgültig von jedem Groupement befreite, ich war nun endlich ein vollkommen freier Mensch geworden, wenn auch nur ein Fabrikarbeiter, aber ich war damit nach all den Leiden reichlich zufrieden, ich war wie gesagt ein freier Mensch.
David Boder: Nun?
Karl Josephy: Nachrichten von meinem Kind sind mir regelmäßig zugekommen, das Kind gedeihte und war recht gut gehalten, es ist nur infolge der Kriegserscheinungen, denn man darf nicht vergessen, das meine Frau das Kind zur Welt gebracht hat nach einem furchtbaren Lager, wo sie ebenfalls interniert war, es ist immerhin zu sagen, dass das Kind sehr schwächlich war und dass wir auch da glücklich sein konnten ...
David Boder: Sagen Sie einmal ...
Karl Josephy: ...und dass das Kind lebt.
David Boder: Warten Sie mal, Sie sagen, dass Ihre Frau das Kind zur Welt gebracht hat NACH einem Lager?
Karl Josephy: Nach einem Lager, ganz richtig, denn meine Frau ist aus Belgien gekommen. Sie war belgischer refugee. Und wurde so wie die meisten belgischen jüdischen refugees in ein Konzentrationslager gebracht, das ja an und für sich nicht so schlimm war wie die Deportationslager, wo aber auch die hygienischen Verhältnisse miserabel waren. So musste meine arme Frau ...
Karl Josephy: ... während ihrer Schwangerschaft ...
David Boder: Warten Sie einmal ...
Karl Josephy: Ja ...
David Boder: War das Kind Ihr Kind?
Karl Josephy: Ja. Natürlich.
David Boder: Na ja, wie ist dann ihre Frau nach Belgien gekommen während Ihrer Schwangerschaft?
Karl Josephy: Ich habe ja meine Frau noch nicht gekannt zu der Zeit. Meine Frau ist seinerzeit von Österreich, wie sie mir erzählt hat, nach Belgien ausgewandert, ebenfalls geflüchtet
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... von Belgien nach Frankreich ...
David Boder: ...ja, aber sie war nicht schwanger in Belgien?
Karl Josephy: Nein, nein, nein, nein.
David Boder: ... nu ja, das war ...
Karl Josephy: Nein, ich will, ich will damit nur erwähnen, dass dass das Kind sehr schwach war ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... denn meine Frau hatte, war in einem Lager während dieser Zeit ...
Karl Josephy: also auch die schlechte, an die schlechte Kost angewiesen, und lag auf der nackten Erde... nicht wahr...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ... es hat dazu geschneit, also unter katastrophalen Verhältnissen ...
David Boder: ...ja, und war nicht gerade fertig, eine Mutter zu bekommen.
Karl Josephy: ... ja, ganz richtig nicht wahr, und man hat dazu ...
David Boder: ...ja, nun, und wo ist das Kind jetzt?
Karl Josephy: Das Kind ist jetzt mit uns - ich habe ...
David Boder: Leben Sie schon in Paris ...
Karl Josephy: Ich lebe jetzt in Paris, ich bin nach Paris zurück gekehrt ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Nachdem wir noch in der letzten Zeit viel mitmachen mussten ...
David Boder: Oh ...
Karl Josephy: Nachdem ich einmal von einer Patroll, von einer deutschen Patrouille verhaftet worden war ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Und Gottseidank freigelassen wurde. Nachdem wir viele Nächte noch im Wald verbracht haben und nachdem wir, eh, nachdem wir ständig in den letzten Monaten vor der Liberation unser Domizil wechseln mussten, um nicht der Miliz aufzufallen, die uns auf der Spur waren, und so haben wir endlich doch das, den Termin der Liberation erreicht.
David Boder: Na warten Sie mal, das ist mir nicht klar ...
Karl Josephy: Ja?
David Boder: Ihre Frau wurde wann befreit von dem Lager ...
Karl Josephy: Am 16. ...
David Boder: ...während Sie noch arbeiteten für ...
Karl Josephy: Während ich im Holz arbeitete, noch im Wald arbeitete ...
David Boder: Noch im Wald arbeiteten
Karl Josephy: Ja, wurde meine Frau befreit, ...
David Boder: ...und Sie konnte zu Ihnen kommen?
Karl Josephy: ... meine Frau zu Ihnen kommen, sie war von dann ein vollkommen freier Mensch
David Boder: Ja, und dann?
Karl Josephy: Ich bin also dann mit meiner Frau in die kleine Ortschaft herunter, wo die Holzfabrik sich befand ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Und eh, dorten hielten wir uns auf, nicht wahr, bis eh bis April ’45, also noch etwas länger nach der Liberation. Das heißt ...
Karl Josephy: Wir waren ...
David Boder: Und dann, also wann wurden Sie von einer deutschen Patrouille angehalten, sagten Sie?
Karl Josephy: Ja das war eine sehr interessante Sache, ich befand mich im Nachbarort, um Fleisch zu kaufen ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: Und im Moment, wo ich den Fleischerladen verlassen wollte, kam eh, kam eine deutsche Patrouille mit Camions nicht wahr, setzte mir ein Maschinengewehr an den Kopf ...
Karl Josephy: Nicht wahr, und, eh, forderte mich auf, mich ruhig zu verhalten, weil eine, eine Aktion gegen, gegen die Resistance im Gange war...
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Karl Josephy: Ich dachte natürlich, dass ich meine Frau vielleicht nie mehr wiedersehen würde, hatte aber Gottseidank ein falsches Papier bei mir. Das war natürlich eine Notmaßnahme. Und nachdem ich so wenig wie mög-, möglich sprach, haben mich die Leute tatsächlich für einen Franzosen angesehen. Für einen Lothringer, wie es auf meinem Papier vermerkt war. Aber ich wollte tatsächlich in dem Moment ...
David Boder: Sie hatten ein falsches Papier?
Karl Josephy: Ich hatte ein falsches Papier.
David Boder: Das Arbeitspapier würde Sie nicht befreien?
Karl Josephy: Bitte?
David Boder: Das Arbeitspapier würde Sie nicht befreit haben?
Karl Josephy: Nein, die hätten mich sofort verhaftet, denn auf dem Arbeitspapier war ich ein Lothringer, der einen ganz anderen Namen gehabt hat und in Metz geboren war. Und das hat mir auch das Leben gerettet.
David Boder: Wieso haben wann haben sie solch ein Papier aufge ...
Karl Josephy: Das hab ich mir von der Resistance verschafft, für die ich auch gearbeitet habe.
David Boder: Also Sie haben für die resistance gearbeitet.
Karl Josephy: Ich habe ganz kleine Dienste geleistet, ich bin dazu mehr oder weniger dazu gekommen, weil mich die Arbeiter sehr gut gekannt haben und auch oftmals um Übersetzungen gebeten haben , denn sie wussten ja, dass ich Deutsch kann, hatten volles Vertrauen zu mir, und die Ubersetzungen habe ich mit größter Freude für sie gemacht.
David Boder: Ja, was für ein, was für Übersetzungen wurden Sie machen?
Karl Josephy: Ja, das ist sehr leicht zu erklären, es hat sich um Armeebefehle für die deutsche Armee gehandelt ...
David Boder: Aha...
Karl Josephy: Nicht wahr, die, die die Resistance wollte immer wieder wissen, nicht wahr, wo sich deutsche Truppenteile befinden ...
David Boder: Aha ...
Karl Josephy: Um selber arbeiten zu können, und auf diese Weise hatte ich Kontakt mit der Resistance, die mir auf meine Bitte auch sofort ein falsches Papier ausfertigte.
Karl Josephy: Das war natürlich eine Notmaßnahme ...
David Boder: Nun, und was tun Sie jetzt?
Karl Josephy: Ich bin nach Paris zurück gekehrt, ich, eh, habe Arbeit bei den amerikanischen Okkupationsbehörden gefunden, meine Frau ist in der Schneiderei tätig, das ist ja ihr Beruf, wir haben endlich unser Kind bei uns und so leben wir nach wie vor ...
David Boder: Ja ...
Karl Josephy: ...von unserer Arbeit.
David Boder: [In English] Also, this concludes Spool 66 of Mr. Karl Josephy who gave us his story from the internment in Africa and to minute to pass the whole time of occupation here in France as a qualified worker. Paris, August the 23, 1946, Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
Karl Josephy: Bon.